[Music]
the shrieks of winged death the siren
song of destiny and a hell of a lot of
walking forget the one ring these are
the elements that bind the lord of the
rings together across all three films
every lord of the rings film is filled
with a lot of traveling in one form or
another fansite the onering.net
estimates that frodo walks a painstaking
1 800 miles from his front doorstep at
bag end to the fires of mount doom and
that doesn't even factor in the part
where the fellowship splits up and we
start tracking each offshoot we watch
our heroes boat down the great river
ontoin right across the plains of rohan
fly on the backs of eagles and otherwise
walk climb and scramble across dozens of
other middle-earth landscapes mordor
the one place middle-earth we don't want
to see any closer this is the one place
we're trying to get to
getting from point a to point b isn't
just something that happens a lot it's a
central part of the story in the
fellowship of the ring the first primary
objective of our heroes is to get frodo
to rivendell from there the poor hobbit
and his friends are tasked with the even
longer journey of getting to mount doom
no matter what way you slice it
traveling is a huge part of every
installment of this story
the lord of the rings is overloaded with
epic moments these might be a gigantic
dragon shaped firework or black riders
chasing hobbits throughout the shire at
other times the scale increases like
when pippin lights the beacons of gundor
or the ants attack eisenguard epic
battles are also scattered throughout
the story from helms deep to the pelinor
fields to the black gates of mordor
though if there's one element that truly
sums up the epicness of peter jackson's
movies it has to be the new zealand
landscapes
all three films are filled with gorgeous
panoramic shots from the land of the
long white cloud the fellowship of the
ring features a number of mesmerizing
visuals as the fellowship travels south
from rivendell the two towers opens with
the stunning peaks of the misty
mountains menace tirith is shown nestled
into a similar southern edifice in the
return of the king couple these shots
with the right music and you can count
on feeling emotional no matter which of
the three movies you're watching
it doesn't take long for the emotional
roller coaster that is the lord of the
rings to start pulling on everyone's
heartstrings the emotional beats run
throughout the story in many different
forms starting with the warm and fuzzy
sentiment of the shire sam we're still
in the shire what could possibly happen
[Music]
from there the comforts of the hobbit
homeland are quickly replaced by the
thrill of a high-speed chase debris
where soggy gloomy danger continues to
lurk before the ring is whisked away
toward mordor spirits are lifted again
when we get a short rest in rivendell
when gandalf falls in battle with the
balrog everyone's spirits are crushed a
visit to lothlorian arguably
rehabilitates those happy feelings again
only for the audience to witness
bormir's death and the breaking of the
fellowship and that's just the first
movie
every lord of the rings entry is riddled
with epic highs and devastating lows
it's part of the tolkien experience
howard shore's score for the lord of the
rings is rightly considered one of the
greatest elements of the films the
revered composer received not one not
two but three academy awards not to
mention three grammys and two bafta
nominations shore's middle earth
soundtrack is one of the essential
ingredients that tie the lord of the
rings trilogy together it knits together
the three-part lord of the rings story
into a single emotionally uniform
experience the soundtrack is also one of
the few standout elements in the less
loved hobbit trilogy the score of a film
is always important but there are few
greater examples of this than shore's
soundtrack for the lord of the rings
it's an iconic part of all three movies
that moves us to tears sparks joy and
consistently brings fans to the edge of
their seats
the lord of the rings may be a story
filled with never-ending traveling but
the fellowship's collective middle earth
tour is consistently interrupted by one
thing in particular set piece battles in
the first movie there are multiple duels
like aragorn's fight with the ring
wraiths at weathertop the fellowships
tussle with a troll in moria and
gandalf's downing of the balrog on the
bridge of kazadun in the second
installment we see epic clashes like
those at helm's deep and an ant-ridden
eisenguard in the third movie the set
pieces reach a fevered pitch as battles
break out at menace tirith the pelinor
fields and even in front of sauron's own
black gates no matter which movie is in
the queue set piece conflicts are going
to show up and the audience can plan on
a steady dose of action as they work
their way there and back again across
middle earth
he may not look it at first glance or
even at second glance but frodo is one
of the strongest members of the
fellowship the little halfling holds an
inner strength of will that is unrivaled
among dwarves elves men and even wizards
it's an inner courage that prompts
gandalf to tell frodo don't you have
some strength in you
and this comes after frodo arrives at
rivendell after being chased stabbed and
then chased again by black riders while
frodo is a spunky little guy that
doesn't mean he's invulnerable on the
contrary he is steadily tempted by the
ring and eventually becomes so consumed
by it that he is unable to willingly
destroy it this inner struggle against
the ring drags throughout all three
movies which is why one easy lord of the
rings staple is seeing frodo constantly
struggling with the temptation to put on
the ring
in the source material tolkien makes it
clear that gandalf isn't interested in
leading he prefers to orchestrate events
from behind the scenes this prompts
saruman in the fellowship of the ring to
belittle the grey wizard by saying it is
seldom unheard of that gandalf the grey
sought for aid one so cunning and so
wise wandering about the lands and
concerning himself in every business
whether it belongs to him or not in the
return of the king denethor harps on
this too when he accuses gandalf by
saying
thy hope is to rule in my stead to stand
behind every throne north south or west
while gandalf's opponents may criticize
his activities as backdoor politicking
and king making they kind of have a
point he's the one that gets frodo to
leave the shire he helps set the stage
for the council of elrond to send the
ring to mordor he saves theoden he rides
ahead to protect menace tyra he
influences the decision to attack the
black gate but the thing is gandalf
doesn't actually make many of these
decisions he provides information offers
nuggets of wisdom and gently guides
others toward making the right decisions
it's subtle and always done in the name
of good but it doesn't change the fact
that gandalf is tirelessly working
behind the scenes throughout all three
movies
one of the major changes that peter
jackson made when adapting the lord of
the rings books to a shorter cinematic
format was to make aragorn's character a
bit more accessible in the source
material the ranger enters the story as
a hero that is fully aware of and laser
focused on his destiny in the movie
version aragorn is anything but certain
about his future he wrestles with his
heritage and hesitates to step forward
when the time comes this doesn't just
happen in one movie either it's an
ongoing struggle throughout all three
films we first realized he is the exiled
gandurian king when arwen tries giving
him a pep talk by the two towers he
started to hesitantly step into the
limelight particularly when he plays a
key role in the defense of helm's deep
by the return of the king as the title
suggests he finally accepts his role as
a defender of the west and one of the
primary foes of sauron
when the lord of the rings begins
saruman has already been walking around
middle earth in his shriveled wizard
body for thousands of years even so it
appears that his long life and past
experiences haven't toned him down much
quite the opposite saruman finds a way
to get arrogant and uppity in all three
lord of the rings movies in the first
film we see him disrespect gandalf
multiple times including accusing him of
being a pipeweed addict your love of the
halfling's leaf has clearly slowed your
mind
by the second film in the extended
edition we see him insulting worm tongue
on a regular basis and when he appears
for the last time at the start of the
extended edition of the return of the
king the wizard starts hurling insults
and fireballs from the top of his tower
saruman is a powerful wizard he even
creates a giant army of urukai to do his
bidding but the power clearly goes
straight to his head making him
predictably impudent pretty much every
time we see him
there's a lot to love in peter jackson's
middle earth the adaptation is moving
inspiring and flat out gorgeously
produced however even though all of the
ingredients are present to make the
recipe a success that doesn't mean every
single element is praiseworthy on the
contrary there are plenty of nitpicky
things to criticize including some that
show up in every single movie case in
point the black writer screech
the bone chilling sound was reportedly
created with little more than a couple
of plastic cups being rubbed together
along with the real scream of producer
and co-writer and peter jackson's wife
fran walsh and she stood there and she
kind of took a deep breath in
nevertheless the sound is terrifying and
sends shivers down the spine the ring
wraith screech is also terribly and
overwhelmingly consistent throughout all
three movies the ring wraiths show up
early and often hurting the ears of
their enemies and audience alike it
doesn't matter if you're watching frodo
flee from the shire faramir drag his
captured hobbits back to gondor or
menace tirith coming under siege the
ringwraiths are always there screaming
and shrieking and screeching
gollum plays a critical role in the
story he's equal parts necessary victim
and active antagonist
one somewhat odd piece of trivia is that
in every lord of the rings movie gollum
actively tracks frodo yes we see him
doing it three separate times when
gollum is first revealed in the
fellowship of the ring it's in the minds
of morya where he's quietly following
the fellowship in the two towers the
poor wretch is caught tracing frodo and
sam through the labyrinth of steep hills
known as the emini real once he's
seemingly tamed gollum leads his captors
straight to shelob's lair in the return
of the king he appears to have died
tumbling off a cliff but presto he makes
a comeback what is he doing why tracking
down frodo of course
the lord of the rings can be a sad story
it focuses on the slow decline of the
elves and the end of an era that was
once beautiful and full of life and yet
tolkien always wrote with a sense of
hope and with a dash of the unexpected
this led to the author coining the word
eucatastrophe which he personally
defined as the sudden happy turn in a
story which pierces you with the joy
that brings tears which i argued it is
the highest function of fairy stories to
produce the lord of the rings is riddled
with eu catastrophes gandalf's return as
the white wizard is one reinforcements
arriving as helm's deep is about to fall
is another so is the charge of the
rohirum at the battle of the pelanor
fields and the arrival of the eagles at
the black gate one could even argue that
for amir's repentance and heroic death
are a form of you catastrophe compared
to the corruption he was caving into
moments before
i do not know what
strength blood
but i swear to you i will not let the
white city fall
there are many predictable things that
happen throughout the lord of the rings
and a eu catastrophe of one form or
another is definitely one of them it's a
happy fact that collectively makes us
glad and keeps everyone coming back for
more as it should
[Music]